as if we needed a real doctor to tell us
that the protests against coronavirus
social distancing were a bad idea
we now are hearing from top infectious
disease doctor Anthony Fauci who is
saying in clear terms these protests
will backfire these protests will slow
down the economic recovery now the
answer the response is of course
obviously but I'm sure that hearing it
from a doctor will make the protesters
take heed and understand the importance
right wrong protesters over the weekend
were actually caught on video chanting
fire foul Chi I played that video for
you yesterday let's look at yesterday's
Good Morning America on ABC here is
doctor foul Qi saying it himself
and finally sir we're seeing these
protests crop up all across the country
right now including the protests in
Texas and other places where they're
saying fire Anthony foul foul Qi is
wrong they're resisting these stay at
home orders from governors what's your
message back to those protesters yeah
yeah me not I think you know that the
message is that clearly this is
something that is hurting from the
standpoint of economics and the
standpoint of things that have nothing
to do with the virus but unless we get
the virus under control
the real recovery economically is not
going to happen so what you do if you
jump the gun and go into a situation
where you have a big speed spike you're
gonna set yourself back so as painful as
it is to go by the careful guidelines of
gradually phasing into a reopening it's
gonna backfire that's the problem unless
we get the virus under control none of
this matters by reopening now you will
get some short-term economic benefit
there will be nominally businesses that
go back online and start earning some
revenue and start paying some taxes okay
but over the long term the economics are
going to be worse from reopening the way
that these protesters want us to reopen
right now it's genuinely and truly sad
that this is simply another political
disagreement it
just another political football to throw
back and forth the science is clear the
medical world is clear any premature
opening is going to lead to a spike in
cases and in the long run it will cost
us dearly maybe we get three to four
weeks of so-called economic productivity
but it's like the experiments about I
don't remember who did these but there's
these experiments with five-year-olds
where you go in and you put a cookie in
front of them and you say I'm gonna
leave the room if you wait ten minutes
you'll get a second cookie and some of
the little kids are more patient and
they wait and they get that second
cookie and a lot of people can't and
they just eat the cookie anyway tons of
people are stuck on the idea of opening
now without realizing that if we do this
difficult thing we can hopefully open
permanently a little further down the
road instead of opening now and then
having to close again and then opening
and closing endlessly until we have a
treatment and a vaccine so of course dr.
Anthony foul she is correct but
understand that once again it's foul Chi
and science on one side and Trump and
these sycophants on the other side and
we're supposed to believe everything is
just fine and there's no obvious
conflict there except that Trump
recognizes things are so bad that he has
to suspend immigration altogether to the
United States foul Chee says do not open
and do not protest while Donald Trump
said over the weekend liberate Minnesota
liberate Michigan liberate Virginia and
save your great Second Amendment it is
under siege and remember that Trump also
said over the weekend the protesters are
the ones being treated roughly and that
they are protesting in a responsible
manner well I think we do have a so
green guidance but I think some things
are too tough and if you look at some of
the states you just mentioned it it's
too tough not only relative to this but
what they've done in Virginia with
respect to the Second Amendment it's
just a horrible thing they did a
horrible thing the governor and he's the
governor under a cloud to start off with
so when you see what he said about the
Second Amendment when you see what other
states have done no I think I feel very
comfortable go ahead
just to be clear when you talk about
these states on Michigan Minnesota
Virginia do you think that they should
lift their stay at home orders or can
you talk no but I think elements of what
they've done is too much I know it's
just too much you know the elements
because I've already said sir are you
concerned though that people coming out
in protest are going to spread coded to
other people they're congregating in
ways that health experts have said they
should not know these are people
expressing their views I see where they
are and I see the way they're working
they seem to be very responsible people
to me but it's you know they've been
treated a little bit rough this is a
direct contradiction I know who I trust
on it but there are trumpets who want
doctor foul she fired for trying to keep
America safe you need only look at
history to know what the right path is
look at studies of the economic impact
of the 1918 flu in the United States we
have found that the cities that
implemented the early measures and kept
them suffered no adverse economic
effects over the medium term the short
term was bad no doubt but the states
that opened earlier the places that
opened earlier in the 1918 flu pandemic
did better in the short term but much
worse in the medium to long term you've
got a grin and Barrett in the short term
you will do better in the long term we
can't miss the forest for the trees here
and sadly the President of the United
States is actually encouraging these
protesters to do that doctor foul she is
clear the science is clear I don't know
that we're going to actually end up on
the right side of this one we'll have
continued coverage of this and other
stories from today on the david pakman
show Instagram page if you were on
Instagram and I am go to david pakman
show that is our Instagram account while
you're there follow me at David Pakman
my urban garden soil has arrived I am
planting I will be documenting all of it
on my Instagram at David Pakman privacy
calm is one of our sponsors and they're
giving you $5.00 just for using their
free
service at privacy calm / Pakman
privacies of service I've been using for
a while now I love it it saves me a
bunch of headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone instead of
exposing your real credit card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers the payments are withdrawn from
your checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a
no-brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm / Pakman